last time you spent your time introduce
you to the topic of algebra right and I
think the last thing you looked at was
variables variables what are variables
yeah okay so the first thing you said
was okay when we introduced a before
write letters present representing
numbers and we gave it a special name
Jimbo in the letter represents no Bosch
pretty much exactly so when you see a
let up but it's not really a letter it's
a number in disguise we call that a
pretty room that's good but we still
don't know like why they called
variables that's a weird name
what okay so they could be they could be
anything right hmm I think we're getting
closer but we're still not the idea what
does a variable like as a word what does
variable mean yeah that's right so they
appear a variable is it can vary it can
change these numbers they can shift
around they can take different values
depending on what kinds of situations
and expressions you find them in okay
hey plus B equals 12 was it okay good so
you can see the idea here right you've
got two that is the represent numbers
two pretty ones right and the point is
that you can put in lots of things into
a and b and b can change right if i made
a three you would make b92 and the other
one if I made a eleven you would make
beef twelve I would make me one of them
plus one you get the idea
so both these variables right numbers
that could change then we introduced a
whole bunch of laws capital L laws that
govern the way these aren't these pretty
rules these values they interact with
each other now there were three clients
there three kind of sets do you remember
what a that well give you clues they
start with C hey what's the first
mutated I don't blame you I mean it is
commute that's how you say to a
community it's like so anyway but I
think we do say the commutator Wars
plural now there are two what are they
remember what they are
okay all right so
so let's write these out we had some
equations that represent these laws
right wouldn't give me the first one
pause poison what's he giving us he's
give us an example
all the colibri ten volt but I want to
know what's the law itself okay
beyond numbers thank you for that up it
had to be said without a voice
now let's look at this so hopefully you
have this in your book it means to hear
these are the complicated laws okay
they work for addition and
multiplication but not as subtraction of
division yeah is it wouldn't be any
cavite a bet sound we'd work we actually
took that too early
but in my head the way that I think
about these is but it was made people
say what's changing let's change it from
one side to the other the the order is
changing right namely yeah it's reversed
so I called the commutator clause by for
them and textbooks will never call them
this but I just want you to know what's
going on I call it the reversible Ward's
because refers to the fact that addition
and multiplication can be reversed and
they still stay the same
okay you can add numbers and you can add
the backwards you still get the same sum
and it's the same with products okay
good yeah
the associative law is one of the middle
I know you smile the associative all's a
bit weird
again there are two of them someone who
hasn't said anything yet convey to us
yeah
something like this I'm hearing it right
okay right so what I'm gonna go good
back to you don't need to necessarily
writing it but look at where you've got
a really say weird what's what's changed
here the order changed when I reversed
right what's changed here yeah good so
what I've done is I've moved these
brackets here from the first two I move
them over here to the last two and of
course the other associative law is
exactly the same but with multiplication
in all the same spots now this is
important you need to get that these two
are different but they feed off each
other
okay the associative law comes from the
commutator for the commutator laws tell
you you could reverse things get you
conversing so you can do them this first
and or that first doesn't matter now the
associative all kind of takes it to the
next step we put brackets in write it
terms like your order of operations a
brackets like in the middle or they lost
okay first we're on it when do you do
brackets yeah good so like they could be
anywhere in the expression but when you
see them you're like it doesn't matter
that this is first you're going to go to
brackets first right does that make
sense
right in fact in fact brackets that's
what they are that's what the B in
oneness stands for it's right front
right two brackets first so what this is
really saying is if you have three
numbers you might happen to you okay you
can add the first two first and then do
the last one or you get the last you
first it doesn't matter doesn't matter
so these laws are no reversible Wars but
the associative laws I like to think of
them as the any order laws if you are
adding numbers or if you're multiplying
that right you can add and multiply in
any order you like you could have a
hundred numbers so you're adding it
doesn't matter if you start on this end
I don't know in the middle or wherever
you like okay you can place the brackets
which tell you where you should start
and you can place them anywhere what yes
hmm well I'm gonna go on to the next bit
and then hopefully that will tell you
whether it matters or not okay the
distributive or in some ways this is the
most important of the laws okay
what is the distributive law being I
think it's the best name yes can someone
give me a M what is the wor the actual
start of a name you know then what
happens after that
yeah yep okay so you're giving me a good
example I'll write that down in a second
can someone give me what's the what's
the law itself and then I write nu is
now yeah let's let's look at this guy
this is important also you might have
learned before and tell me if you
haven't that there's some shortcuts to
write is particular multiplication right
instead of writing them all twice time
all the time sometimes we just admit it
right so for instance we might like this
and I still read that as a times B plus
C or a multiplied by B plus C so it's
sort of hiding in there I would just say
Shh just pretend he's not there but he's
still doing his thing in the same way
how would you write the right-hand side
whoops this is wrong that should be a
name how would I write that without the
publication signs yes
yeah good now I kind of like this have
you guys seen that before
or is that new yeah raise your hand if
you've seen him cuz okay that's more
like a break down I like this because
without all the time signs there it's a
little easier to see what's going on
what is the distributive law what's
being distributed because we know what
distributing is what's going on if I say
I've got a I've got papers and I'm going
to distribute them to everyone okay that
means I'm giving you all a paper that's
what distributing means right so what's
being distributed here in this line
what's going on someone hasn't said
anything yet okay yeah I've got three
numbers here right which is the number
that I'm multiplying by it's not that
this is a number this is a number as
well the one that I see being added on
to multiply bond to the others is the
egg you see this
there's the a there the a got
distributed to the B key go have a name
enjoy yourself okay and then the egg
gets distributed to here as well it gets
given to the C at the same time now the
way I like to picture this is a bit like
let's say mr. a yeah okay
here you go this mr. a right mr. a comes
to visit a nude house right and it's got
inside two people
and see now guys know if you don't know
it already right if you ever come to
someone's house right you should say
hello to everyone in sight it's not that
nice to like kind of just say hello to
your friend of minutes or ignore
everyone else in there sir just a is
polite it says hello B and then it says
hello say and that's what this is right
is one greedy men and then and we call
it bit of a jerk if I if you were like C
and he just said hi to B and then ignore
t you'd be like okay but that's right
but you know this is the way we want to
do it to make sure we do it all the way
across and find something else yeah
let's expand a little bit you didn't see
this before but I think you could work
out what it would do if there were not
two people in the house but three what
would you expect that to be equal to
yeah Desmond so we're on mister a right
he has a lot of people to greet but
that's the way what's because all these
people they're all in the house I then I
have to greet each other because they're
in the house they're one family but a
greets everyone right okay good
that was revision rule it off yeah
question